Film Courage: When you finish a screenplay
on spec, what’s protocol when you’re done?
Blayne Weaver: You finish it up and get all
of your buddies to read it and tell you what
you think because this is like you only get
one first read on that.
And this is hard for me because I like to
get it out there, see what the agent thinks
(as soon as possible) and…it’s a mistake!
You should hold it until it’s done.
I have trouble taking that advice but…you
send it to your agent or producers or whoever
your contacts are in the world and you wait
to see what they say.
It’s pretty simple.
You have very little power over it once they
take it.
I have this one script that has had overwhelmingly
positive feedback and notes and has been at
one agency for about 8 months…you know…going
through actors, big movie stars reading it
or their “people” reading it.
Anyways, we will wait for 9 weeks and then
we will hear “Well, Matthew McConaughey
just passed, but that’s okay.
We’re going to Woody Harrelson.”
Okay…9 weeks later “Well, Woody Harrelson
passed, but that’s okay.
We’re going to Josh Brolin.”
And it just sits there and people read it
and you know, I do nothing.
I just sit and I’m happy that these agencies
and this talent has something of mine to read.
You know, maybe they will see my name on it.
Film Courage: What if you don’t have the
agent or manager to give it to?
I mean, let’s say you are a new writer that
doesn’t have a foundation, hasn’t been
in Los Angeles that long?
Blayne Weaver: There are online resources.
“The Blcklst” is one of them where you
can send in the script and have it covered,
have it read.
Coverage is this thing where it’s like a
book report on your script where they…all
the studios do that, they’ll give you a
little score, you know?
And you can pay people to do it professionally.
But I would say that right now, these competitions,
like I know the Austin Film Festival has a
very prestigious one, but sending your script
in if you win a couple of awards, that’s
something that might get some leeway in sending
it to an agency.
Normally I would say that almost never works.
I’ve never heard of anybody being read because
of a query letter.
But if you have awards, maybe it would work?
I mean look, there is no set way to do anything
in this business.
Like everything is a twisty-turny, chutes
and ladders kind of thing.
So you just try everything.
You just throw everything at it and I mean
that’s how I finance movies.
That’s how I got all of my movies done.
You just try everything and see what works
out and be open to something working out in
a way that you didn’t expect.